[Música]
a inteligência artificial deve ser
compreendida e usufruída não temida o
senso comum aponta que as pessoas têm
medo de perder seus empregos e
privacidade de suas relações humanas
trocadas por relações por computadores e
que os robôs dominaram a humanidade
mas essa é uma visão incompleta e que
tem sido amplificada através de filmes e
mídia sem rigor científico
por outro lado pouco divulgado sobre
como inteligência artificial já está
ajudando a vida dos humanos e o convite
aqui é para compreendermos mais
aplicações e ao invés de temermos
entendermos o que nós precisamos fazer
para convivermos com a inteligência
artificial
vamos então compreendê la através de
exemplos práticos do nosso dia a dia
sabe quando a gente cria um perfil no
instagram no facebook ou qualquer outra
rede social e ela nos ajuda a ampliar as
nossas conexões ao sugerir pessoas que a
gente já conhece
então esse é um tipo de algoritmo de
inteligência artificial chamado sistema
de recomendação que também é encontrado
no youtube no spotify e na amazon
sugerindo vídeos músicas e produtos que
a gente ia gostar quando a gente faz uma
compra no cartão de crédito e
administradora nega transação por
suspeita de fraude
a administradora teve uma pequena fração
de tempo para analisar dados da compra
como data hora e local produto e preço e
comparar com o meu perfil de compra essa
detecção de fraude
ela pode ser implementada com um
algoritmo de inteligência artificial
chamado detecção de anomalias um outro
tipo de aplicação muito utilizado nos
dias de hoje é a otimização derrotas
seja para a logística de grande porte ou
para os mapas do dia a dia
no b
ajudando a aliviar o trânsito nas
grandes cidades
fazer com que a gente chegue mais rápido
nós nos nossos destinos e que a pizza
que a gente pede nossas casas chega
ainda quente agora e um relógio de
corrida onde tem inteligência artificial
em um relógio de corrida
quero começar de que o relógio decorrida
em forma para a gente a quantidade de
calorias que nós gastamos no exercício
só que o fato é que houve uma medição
técnica real da quantidade de calorias
um software do relógio avalia a
distância percorrida o local o horário a
inclinação o batimento cardíaco e cruza
esses dados conformidade com o meu peso
dessa forma ele consegue predizer a
quantidade de calorias que foram gastas
isso é feito com uma técnica chamada
regressão que é a capacidade de predizer
a quantidade qualquer tipo de número e
essa regressão ela está presente em
vários tipos de soluções em inteligência
artificial no mundo como um todo agora e
o google tradutor o google tradutor
ajuda e já salvou muita gente no
trabalho e nas viagens google tradutor
tem uma inteligência artificial focada
em linguagem que a gente chama de
processamento de linguagem natural que
também é utilizada na criação de
assistentes virtuais e chat botes que
conseguem entender a palavra falada
escrita processo a ela e dar um retorno
apropriado uma outra aplicação que
poucas pessoas conhecem é a detecção do
sentimento ea personalidade de uma
pessoa através da palavra falada ou da
palavra escrita
isso pode ser utilizado na identificação
de trotes em chamadas para ambulâncias
para polícias e pra qualquer outro tipo
de serviço
agora uma entrevista especial é muito
boa quando analisa imagens e vídeos como
por exemplo a detecção de câncer de pele
cuja performance já se equipara a
performance
da mesma forma câmeras de hoje já
conseguem escrever uma cena para um
deficiente visual que vai ter uma vida
cotidiana muito melhor
igualmente os locais públicos estão mais
seguros através de deslocamento
preditivo de policiais além de além da
identificação de fugitivos e pessoas
desaparecidas
a robótica avançada também é um campo da
inteligência artificial ea automação
industrial é a principal área de
aplicação
hoje em dia já existem diversos tipos de
robôs construindo componentes
eletrônicos carros e vários outros tipos
de itens em alta escala para atender o
mercado global cada vez mais a gente vai
ver a miniaturização desses robôs
fazendo atividades domésticas e muitos
de vocês já devem ter ouvido falar
daqueles robôs que varrem as nossas
casas e agora já tem aqueles que dobram
passar roupa
tem aqueles que fazem receitas nas
nossas próprias cozinhas sem contar
aqueles que torna a vida de pessoas
idosas solitárias um pouco mais fácil um
pouco melhor quando a gente reúne várias
dessas aplicações de inteligência
artificial a gente vai ter cada vez mais
soluções sofisticadas como é o caso dos
carros autônomos que tenha embarcado uma
série de tecnologias
eu citei apenas alguns exemplos de
aplicações de inteligência artificial
que estão ao nosso redor e já está claro
que nós já estamos colhendo muitos
benefícios dela
agora será que existe alguma coisa que a
inteligência artificial não consegue
fazer sim
isso porque até agora a gente falou
sobre o wiki e william é aquela que
também conhecida como inteligência
artificial fraca é aquela que faz muito
bem
aquelas coisas para as quais ela foi
elas foram construídas e treinadas
agora a strong ae ou artifício ou
general impede sou inteligência
artificial geral
ela se assemelha mais com a inteligência
dos seres humanos e estes são apenas
alguns exemplos que ela não consegue
fazer bem
ela não consegue ter uma empatia
verdadeira com o outro com humano ou com
uma outra inteligência artificial
ela não consegue ser criativa a partir
do nada ela não consegue ainda com um
pouco uma música reconhecida por outros
humanos como de altíssima qualidade
ela não consegue responder todas as
coisas ela não consegue explicar o
racional de todas as suas respostas e
decisões não consegue tomar decisões
morais
ela também não consegue realizar uma
série de atividades complexas conectadas
em si com o objetivo de longo prazo e
passar no teste de turing ela também não
consegue que é a capacidade de se passar
por uma inteligência humana sem que um
ano perceba que ela é artificial e nem
passar no teste do café que é quando tem
um humanóide dotado de inteligência
artificial
consegui entrar em qualquer caso
aleatória e fazer um café pra ela eu
encerro esses exemplos com a capacidade
de predizer o futuro do universo é o
maior partido do terror em volta da
inteligência artificial também estranhar
que ainda não existe para que ela exista
vão ser necessários múltiplos avanços
tecnológicos como foi o caso do piloto
ni uma técnica de i a que foi utilizada
em vários desses exemplos que se tem
portanto as nações ainda tem tempo para
construir em leis políticas e abrirem
espaços de discussão para que o avanço
da inteligência artificial não crie
problemas para a humanidade
e esse tipo de diálogo e discussão já
está ocorrendo em várias partes do mundo
contando com empresas formadores de
opinião e governo
e falando em transformação é é um dos
principais medos da sociedade perdeu
emprego para a inteligência artificial
eu quero começar do ponto de vista de
que o nosso mercado de trabalho é muito
dinâmico e sim as pessoas perdem o
emprego ea demanda por trabalho
por diversos motivos inclusive quando
uma pessoa se torna defasada em relação
aos outros mas agora existem aquelas
profissões ou trabalhos que a sociedade
simplesmente não vi mais valor como por
exemplo um despertador humano
o entregador de leite e um arrumador de
pinus de boliche tem também um acendedor
de postes e agora existem aquelas
profissões que o trabalho dela é útil
ainda para a sociedade
só que não é mais necessário um
trabalhador por executar ela porque o
próprio cidadão faz por ele mesmo
inclusive de outras formas como por
exemplo um atendente do estacionamento
um ascensorista do elevador
um balconista de um restaurante fast
food ou até mesmo operador de caixa
bancário e agora tem várias profissões
que estão em processo de transformação
elas estão cada vez mais sendo
executadas por robôs com inteligência
artificial como é o caso de montadoras
de carro
condutores de trem de metrô contadores e
até advogados de causa simples
qual será o motivo quais são os motivos
para uma empresa escolheu automatizam
trabalho ao invés de deixar um
trabalhador para fazer
são vários mas vou citar alguns
primeiro executar mais gastando menos
segundo executar mais mantendo a mesma
qualidade terceiro fazer algo que seja
complexo demais o perigoso demais para
um ser humano portanto no futuro não vai
existir esse conceito de estabilidade de
emprego e nem aquela pessoa que não quer
evoluir ou aprender novas habilidades
inclusive hoje já existem uma série de
novos empregos e profissões e ao longo
dos próximos anos várias outras serão
criadas nessa nova realidade
nós vamos precisar ser continuamente uma
visão empreendedora sobre quais são as
atividades que realmente
agregam valor para a sociedade e para as
pessoas
nós vamos precisar ter uma mentalidade
muito mais de empreendedorismo além da
de funcionários que hoje nós temos uma
capacidade ampla de fazer networking
porque no futuro nada vai ser feito
sozinho e uma capacidade de ter uma
gestão financeira mais ajustada para
construir uma segurança financeira nesse
mercado de trabalho mais dinâmico
de forma geral nós vamos precisar ser
muito mais donos e responsáveis pelas
nossas próprias carreiras quer sejamos
empregados e empregadores aqueles que
estão trabalhando vão precisar monitorar
muito mais as suas profissões
enquanto se preparam para as novas
eles vão aqueles que por algum motivo
perderam seus empregos
vamos precisar encontrar formas
criativas e modernas de gerar renda
enquanto se preparam para as novas
profissões e aquele que por algum motivo
ou outro não conseguem retornar para o
mercado de trabalho que ele vai ter que
fazê lo ele vai depender do governo
o governo o governo vai ser fundamental
nesse novo nesse novo mercado de
trabalho nós
ele vai precisar criar leis e programas
para proteger proteger o trabalhador e
não profissões que estão se tornando
obsoletas em todo o mundo e várias ações
do governo já estão corretor acontecendo
ao redor do mundo como por exemplo a
exercício de renda básica universal e
também a preparação massiva de
profissionais em novos tipos de trabalho
novo um outro tipo de preocupação que a
sociedade tenha de perder a privacidade
ideal a privacidade das pessoas
o ideal é que a gente encontra uma
solução que garanta a privacidade dos
das pessoas ao mesmo tempo em que
permite que a inovação seja desenvolvida
e que nós sejamos beneficiados por ela
vamos então analisar
o cenário do governo das empresas do
cidadão e dos hackers por natureza os
governos têm múltiplos dados e acesso à
informação acesso por lei
há vários tipos de informação nesse caso
vai ser necessário ter investimento
suficiente para que haja um investimento
em tecnologias modernas de segurança da
informação para proteger os nossos dados
os dados do cidadão já as empresas elas
já as empresas elas colhem dados
compartilham todos os dias com várias
pessoas dados de pessoas de clientes etc
e nesse caso o que é importante é que
tenhamos leis e nós já temos leis para
regulamentar esse processo de coleta e
tratamento desses dados na europa a
gente tem a gbr e no brasil a gente tem
a lei geral de proteção de dados e os
cidadãos
os cidadãos estão em diariamente
postando comentando curtindo
compartilhando criando vídeos imagens
áudios nas plataformas redes sociais etc
esses dados são muito legais muito
importantes e úteis para a sociedade
como um todo mas há que se ter cuidado
nesse caso que a gente precisa ter é
cada vez mais investimento em
alfabetização digital que aquele tema
que ensina os perigos reais de segurança
da informação em uma sociedade digital e
os hackers aqueles que estão cometendo
crimes cibernéticos todos os dias
bom o governo vai precisar mais do que
leis é preciso ter capacidade de
fiscalização capacidade de julgamento
especializado e também a de aplicar
punições eu encerro aqui com uma
reflexão de que nós vamos precisar estar
muito mais abertos a fazer as coisas
rotineiras de formas mais modernas
entendermos que nós não precisamos fazer
todo o trabalho manual
a inteligência artificial vai nos dar
muito mais tempo livre pra gente fazer
aquelas coisas que a gente realmente
gosta
nós vamos precisar ser muito mais
empreendedores para continuamente
encontrarmos nichos de atuação que
realmente agrega valor às pessoas e para
a sociedade
vamos precisar entender que nosso
mercado agora é global e não somente a
nossa cidade local
vamos precisar compreendendo exigências
oficial experimentá-la e continuamente
transformar a nossa forma de viver
obrigado
[Música]